while there is hope an agreement can be
made with the transition period ending
in a month it is essential of course
that both sides
have preparations in place for a no deal
well dmitry uh griezbinski is um
is the founder of explain trade and he
fears not nearly enough
preparation uh has been done a very good
afternoon
uh to you uh appears that it's sort of
glacial
progress but what do you make of the the
optics of michelle barnier coming in
person
to london at the start of the weekend
it's certainly better than the
alternative which is him having to stay
in brussels either because he thinks
there's no point
or because of covert complications and
i'm glad he and the team
seem to be well but at the end of the
day uh
this isn't something that is going to be
resolved between mr vanya and mr frost
this is something that is going to be
resolved between mr johnson and the
eu leaders so while there it's a good
sign it is
by no means not the the critical thing
that needs to happen
what do you think the actual deadline is
i mean our correspondent there was
saying
you know things are going to get pretty
dicey if we get to the end of next week
and there's still
no deal i would never argue with mr
parsons about understanding eu mechanics
uh i think probably what he's saying
makes a lot of sense it's also worth
noting that the closer you push
the agreement to uh the end of the
transition period
the more you squeeze the european
parliament's time to consider it
the angrier they get the european
parliament is very jealous
of its sovereignty and of its role and
if you try to lean on them by giving
them less time
they get angry and they find ways to to
come back at you later
um so in addition to whether it's
possible it's
there are other consequences as well
yeah i mean it has to be ratified as you
say
by all those uh individual states um do
you see any of the individual eu
members starting to make life difficult
at the last minute
uh again if anything is possible in the
european union um i certainly think that
if the deal doesn't reflect
uh one of their interests they could
make a they could make a fuss
everyone's always looking to france who
have been the the sort of bad cop in the
relationship for most of their
negotiations
i think if the deal isn't there on
fisheries in the way france likes
or if uh or if president macron simply
wants to
uh i suppose as a political statement uh
make some noise it's entirely possible
they cause a problem
but at the end of the day michelle
barnier won't sign an agreement or
recommend an agreement for signature
if he doesn't feel like the eu member
states are behind him that is his role
and he takes that very seriously
um the other um the other thing that we
need to talk about really is this
specter of
no deal and i was reading out there in
in my introduction that
you say uh preparations have not gone
anywhere near
far enough well let's be absolutely
clear
preparations for the end of transition
have not gone far enough and have not
advanced
uh as much as we would like them to uh
the facilities that the ports aren't
ready
businesses aren't ready that's not a no
deal
thing whether there's a deal or not
businesses
operating across that border will face
immense new hurdles
as they effectively become exporters
into the european union
or importers from it that is going to
happen whether there's a deal or not
and everything we're hearing from the
ground the tests that we are seeing when
you know even france pilots part of its
border procedures
and now suddenly gridlock intent the
development of it systems
none of that is where you would want it
to be on the government side
and my my colleagues who talk to
businesses all the time about their
preparations
are looking frankly more and more action
on the things they're hearing
businesses aren't ready many of them
don't have the information they need to
even begin becoming ready
and they are very very nervous well
what's your read of it though i mean i
suppose you i mean you could say it's
just poor organization
uh or you could say that perhaps it's
it's the mark of a government which
doesn't
which won't let it happen
i don't think the government has any
capacity to stop it
at the moment the transition the
opportunity to extend the transition
period ended five months ago
maybe if the government had turned
around and decided they needed an
extension
three four months ago and turned around
to the european union and said hey
we missed that deadline but we changed
our minds can we do something
maybe the european union would have
extended it but
at this point i don't think there's
capacity to extend transition
the negotiations over what that would
look like would probably be more complex
than what's left on the table in the fta
um in the free trade agreement
negotiations so i don't think they have
the capacity to extend it
whether this is a function of government
disorganization
i'm not in a position to say what i will
say is it feels like
active preparations began far later in
the uk
than they did in the european union
businesses had information far later
construction began far later and i think
that was a function in part of politics
while i think the brexit project had a
specter of doubt over it of whether it
would be overturned or
whether there'll be a second referendum
or whatever um the government didn't
feel like it had the freedom
to admit there would be any negative
consequences from brexit at the end of
the transition
well i suppose i only that they felt
like they could
we're running out of time i suppose we
are where we are um
dimitri
i'm just really wondering whether i mean
we talk
a lot don't we about the three sticking
points here which have been the same
sticking points for a long time you've
got competition you've got governance
and you've got fish how stuck are those
and
what's your perspective on which of
those might give
from a trade perspective there are
landing zones on all three
where both sides would get economically
what they need
on how politically stuck they are how
much boris johnson feels like he could
sell a
compromise a halfway on fish or
level playing field or state aid to his
party
and how much the michelle barnier and
the commission
feel like they could sell a compromise
to the eu member states
that's a much much more difficult
question and one i don't think anyone
really knows the answer to
we'll just have to wait and see yes
indeed we will won't we uh dimitri
uh groszabinski thank you very much for
your time on sky news thank you so much